we saw this week that it may not take
cutting-edge technology to achieve a
similar goal amid his feud with Nancy
Pelosi President Trump tweeted out a
video of the House Speaker that was
edited to make her appear to stammer
during a news conference that was
followed by a second altered video of
Pelosi that made the rounds on social
media Jeff Pegues has that part of the
story since we took here is the real
video of House Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
then he had a press conference in the
Rose Garden with all this short sort of
visuals now the doctor video in which
she appears to be impaired and then he
had a press conference in the Rose
Garden with all this sure visuals that
clip received more than two and a half
million views on Facebook the video is
really at a pretty low tech fake where
Connie Fareed a professor of computer
science at the University of California
Berkeley says this video is just the tip
of the iceberg of how videos and images
can be manipulated the most standard one
is to take an image or a video of a
person candidate a president and alter
it to make it look like they are saying
something that they never said that is
called deep fakes in this example former
President Barack Obama's voice has been
altered ben Carson is in the sunken
place the voice behind this video is
actor Jordan Peele the use of alter Dios
is led US intelligence officials to
issue a warning ahead of the 2020
elections this year's worldwide threat
assessment says adversaries and
strategic competitors would likely
attempt to use deep fakes to influence
campaigns in the US but they could also
be used for other nefarious reasons what
if somebody creates a video of President
Trump saying I've launched nuclear
weapons against Iran or North Korea or
Russia and we don't have hours or days
to figure out if it's real or not and
the implications of getting that wrong
are phenomenally high and what you have
to understand about this technology is
that it's not in the hands of a few it
is in the hands of many the video
remains on Facebook because the company
does not have a policy that stipulates
whatever you post must be true
meantime YouTube has removed the Pelosi
videos or CBS this morning Saturday Jeff
McGee's Washington well there's a couple
of issues there that you got to deal
with one of the fact that they get left
up right which is a major problem and
just the fakes themselves I mean we were
joking sort of about the Mona Lisa but
this is really in the worst form that
you could use it as seeing is no longer
believing no matter richer its McGarry
place
yes it's making life very complicated